all right as we continue with our angel
parents all having lost loved ones their
children to illegal immigrants we only
have five minutes left I just want to
maybe run through some it's obviously a
big national political debate what's
your reaction to this is a manufactured
crisis what words do you want to say to
the president
Nancy Chuck what do you say I would like
to invite Nancy and Chuck Schumer to my
son's grave on January 28th so they can
celebrate or not celebrate cry with me
at his grave at his manufactured grave
this is permanent family separation what
separates the family Sherman and family
separation like my shirt says and what
separates me and my son is not a fence
it's six feet of dirt and the coffin how
many of you have met the president so
all of you all of you have and I
remember we did a show during the
campaign I got emotional in that show
and I'm sure you will at some point too
and you're watching the president fight
and you're hearing the manufacturer of
crisis what do you want to say to them
Steve you know it Chuck Schumer Nancy
Pelosi you're just hypocrites and I'm
being just flat-out honest as hypocrite
you yourself have shown video clips of
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer telling
people we need this wall we need to stop
the the an Obama was president
absolutely so what changed what just
because votes what global economy
they're hypocrites it's disgusting
what do you say dingbat I mean what one
week she wants the wall the next week
she doesn't want the wall she doesn't
want to give any money toward it I think
it's what 1/10 of 1% of money offered at
all is 1/10 of 1% of the budget
she won't give it it's a it's absurd I
think that blood is on her hands she
absolutely took enough to protect
American citizens she's not doing it she
doesn't even want to try just because
she hates Trump I don't know what's
wrong with her I'm not you happy the
president's holding the line
I'm very happy and you know I've said
this before but I would love the
opportunity to stand in front of Nancy
Pelosi mother to mother and look her in
the eye and say which child of yours or
your grandchild of yours would you give
up to support this agenda that you're
this this this horrendous lie the
desecration of our children on our loved
ones lives it's like it's a slap in our
face on the kicked our loved ones grave
every time she does this and I want the
public to know and I want Nancy Pelosi
to know I called her office again today
and requested another meeting next week
when I'm in DC yeah I guess Helen it was
over you had silence from her staffer I
said this is angel mom Mary Amadou so
I'd like to request a meeting
face-to-face mother-to-mother with Nancy
Pelosi about this this situation dead
silence and the staffer said no I'll put
you through you can leave a voicemail so
this is how Nancy Pelosi is very
question yes on the town hall I asked
her Nancy you know I told her what
happened to Josh and you know I said
which child you know could you sacrifice
for this and you know she just glazed
over and oh we're praying for you and
but I just need to let you know that
every every person in our sanctuary
cities a law-abiding citizen let me ask
about the media I've just played the
media echoes the exact words of what the
Democrats are saying manufacturer crisis
you I'm sure you guys will watch TV
alright well hopefully you don't watch
fake news but yeah well Nancy Pelosi I
have my only child's ashes in this urn I
carry his ashes in a little locket this
is the last time I got to touch my child
that's on in the morgue
those are his bruised cold dead hands
with me touching him and kissing him the
last time and she doesn't just have
blood on her hands she needs boots
because that blood is rising she's
knee-deep in it and if she doesn't get
with the president to end this she's
gonna need boots all the way up to her
thigh because it's getting worse they
need to get it are you angry with the
media yeah
but the use of words pop weak for you
people just watching all this and here
in the same words every day
liberals were so compassionate this is
preventable in our country when the
sanctuary state City issue where you
can't criminal aliens not just people
that came here that want a better life
energy in jail they let them go and
basically assist them out the door so
they don't get deported that got justice
through the criminal court system for
Joshua I don't think anybody else has
done that and thank you Texas for that
but I mean it does have some sort of
that you know he's there for a long time
but other than that I don't think
anybody else really got justice we're
gonna end this here I wanna I want to
personally come over and thank you I
know it simple to thank you I'm sorry so
much really I'm the pain I know so good
to see you again
you're so strong I hope you get that
meeting your daughter so beautiful
really and your son thank you Trump's
wall this is America's wall right what
can have a door to Steve thank you you
son grant amazing so good to see you
thank you so much I know this is the
hardest time for both of you this just
happened the twenty nine to the December
you're in our prayers okay always thank
you for sharing your story I hope
America hears and more specifically I
hope these idiots in DC listen and the
president I think he's going to hold the
line and they'll do one way another